Marc wicker he's been covering la sports
for a long time working for the LA Daily
News a columnist and caught my attention
where I think using the words panic
button and Marc kind enough to join us
Marc good morning how are you good I'm
doing okay are the Lakers okay boy
that's to be determined and they weren't
okay the other night they're done 41 to
10 in the first quarter and you know
they made Serge Ibaka look like Elgin
Baylor and you know it there's a it's an
under-construction type of thing you
know when you look back at the teams
that LeBron went to like Miami and then
Cleveland the second time they didn't
get out of the gate really quickly
either so there's but there's a lot of
moving parts here that they have to put
together and except the Luke Walton to
do that as long as he's got the
opportunity to how long does he have
that opportunity well we saw a
three-time Stanley Cup wearing coach get
fired yesterday so who knows but you
know I would think that if they have a
lot of outings like the one the other
night where they basically was kind of
lost and granted they were playing a
really good team in Toronto I don't
think he can afford a lot of those
because there's there's going to be
pressure this from pressure from within
the room because you know LeBron you
know this has got something to prove and
there's got something to to shoot for
and then there's pressure from
everywhere else because Laker fans have
been through the wringer here the last
few years and they expected a better
team than this whether that's realistic
or not yeah and that's what I wonder
mark I kept saying you got to preach
patience with this this is just a
feeling out first year let's see what we
have they're gonna be pieces they're
gonna be back in pieces it won't be back
do can you see a scenario where they
decide that they want to continue to try
to be relevant make the playoffs you
know and they trade one of the younger
pieces here I think they have to make
some sort of roster alteration whether
to get another shooter or to get a
shooter because they really don't have
that many and to get better underneath I
mean they they sigh enticing Chandler
but they basically have him in JaVale
McGee and you know there really aren't
that strong at the rim they've got a lot
of perimeter
guys they've got a lot of guys like
Rondo ball and James who are accustomed
to having the ball at crunch time and
there's only one of those basketballs
out there so it's kind of an oddly put
together roster which which is you could
use that as a defense of Luke Walton
that you know he hasn't really been
given a smooth-running roster the other
thing is when you look at the West I
think everybody underestimated how good
the West is even though we all knew it
was good but Denver is you know looks
like an outstanding team
Utah's better San Antonio's better New
Orleans is there along with the usual
suspects Oklahoma City Golden State in
Houston so all these predictions that
the Lakers are going to have home court
in the first round might be a little out
of way I thought if they got to 50 wins
I give LeBron the MVP eye I thought it
was gonna be a Herculean task because
you know being on the East Coast I got
to see the Cavs every night they played
and I saw what they were playing against
and you could go through the motions and
and get to you know 55 wins you can't go
through the motions in the West there
it's rare when you have an off night you
know when you're you're gonna face some
of these teams and everybody wants a
piece of the Lakers they're gonna want a
piece of LeBron here and I wonder about
Magic Johnson's role in all of this mark
as a player he controlled the tempo it's
hard to control this in his position and
it feels like if you're already getting
frustrated with Luke Walton this early
in the season this doesn't end well
yeah Magic's very demanding boss you saw
that in his brief coaching career I mean
he he had a very high standard for
himself and he expects everybody else or
the employees to have that standard
which is good to a point but it
certainly leads to impatience and
tension and and I think you're right the
other factor in the West is the LeBron
has never dealt with before is you know
the travel is different I mean you're
not back in your you know you're not
flying back to Cleveland from Washington
and Atlanta and Detroit and all these
places and getting the home by midnight
you know your your trips are longer and
it's more grueling and you're playing
better teams so yes I think a lot of us
and a lot of other people probably had
the bar a little bit too high for this
team but again you know and in Miami and
Cleveland at some point LeBron got the
things straightened out and they started
winning so I think we at least need to
give them you know 10 15 more games
before we see Algar there can you have
lungs oh and rajon rondo coexist here
and looking at the development of one
syllable if that is a goal of this -
it's really hard because you know
neither one of them are known for being
great off the ball players and even
though ones I was shooting the ball a
little better I mean that's not what he
does that's not his identity and Rondo
again you know it's one of the great
minds to ever play point guard but he's
not one of those guys that stands out by
the 3-point line and you give him the
ball after you put a trade and draw the
defense and and LeBron in the end is
going to have that role anyway at the
end of games that's why the roster is a
little bit convoluted and then you know
they're the Laker fans look at New
Orleans and they say well we let Julius
Randle go he with ten for ten years is
arriving playing with Anthony Davis I
mean just a lot of questions about how
this team was put together okay so who
has to be on their wish list who they
have to get next year next year well
I've always thought from the beginning
that Kawhi Leonard would be a really
good fit whether that happens or not
whether he likes whether he comes to
like Toronto or not you know he said
from the beginning whenever he has
talked which isn't very often that that
Los Angeles is in his sight so I would
assume we start there I know there's a
lot of people talking about Anthony
Davis and you know when you live in LA
and you listen to Laker fans every great
player wants to come to Los Angeles I
mean you go back to you know Hakeem
Olajuwon Dominique Wilkins if you listen
to Laker fans they'll tell you well you
know and deep in his heart he wants to
be a Laker well you know not everybody
does but Kawhi Leonard has said that he
wants to play out here whether it's for
the Lakers for the Clippers and I would
think that would that would be priority
number one unless he decides he likes
Toronto the same way Paul George like
Oklahoma City yeah I just don't see his
personality makeup fitting in with
LeBron and the Lakers I I just don't
think Hawaii wants to be part of a
boyband
and I just think he's
he's San Antonio was perfect for him
Toronto it feels like would be perfect
for him I I wouldn't be surprised if he
stays in Toronto I really wouldn't I
just don't think his personality is and
plus it takes a lot you have to be ready
to play with LeBron because you're sort
of playing for LeBron and not everybody
is wired that way and that I think that
klay Thompson would be the guy that I
would I would have to have because he
opens things up I don't need the other
point guards there I gotta have somebody
who's gonna I can put Kuzma with and and
we can stretch the defense a little bit
here and LeBron can go back to being
LeBron and he would be the target I'd
want clay over Kawhi basically I asked
him why would you ever leave where you
are I mean you got you've got a license
to print championships right I agree but
does Durant stays if he's got a license
to print championships as well it feels
like Durant may leave so I don't know if
that means that clay would want to stay
more or I don't know I just I I go is so
interesting to try to dissect from afar
with these guys if what they want to do
where they want to do it how they want
to do it but I mean you're right I would
stay with Golden State I have fun who
cares it for the bad guys we're winning
championships we're gonna be Hall of
Famers we're getting paid and we're
moving into a new building so you know
what's not to like and you live in a
great city not a net this box is a great
example of the guy who was a terrific
player went to play with Miami and then
early on seemed to realize it look you
know one of us is going to have to take
a back seat here yeah and make it all
work and that's why I've always had a
lot of respect for him because he
accepted that and he changed his game to
make the Miami Heat
work because LeBron takes up a lot of
energy and takes up a lot of space in
the locker room on the court and
everywhere else
he's the dominant figure and so
everybody else kind of has to defer to
that and you know you got a bunch of
young guys on the Lakers who are trying
to make a mark in this game and whether
that that opportunity or whether that
process is
they're not hasn't been very smooth so
far the other thing I think they played
too fast there's been so much emphasis
Lukas said it magic said it we got to
play fast and I think that ends up
leading to bad shots by team with not a
lot of good shooters and then it affects
your defense because if you're missing
shots the other team running and they
haven't been all that good transition
way either but you know like we said
let's let's wait and see 10 15 games and
see what they look like then mark thanks
for joining us we appreciate your time
thank you Dan appreciate it it's more
quicker LA Daily News for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]